okay now for our final speaker of this
national leadership seminar Sydney
Powell has practiced law for many years
primarily in the fifth US Circuit Court
of Appeals
she has been lead counsel and more than
500 federal appeals 350 of them as an
assistant United States attorney and
appellate section chief in the western
and northern districts of Texas she is a
past president of the American Academy
of appellate lawyers and the Bar
Association of the 5th Federal Circuit
and she is a member of the American Law
Institute many of you have heard or seen
one of her frequent appearances on radio
and television including Lou Dobbs
Hannity shannon bream laura ingram news
max one american news and mark levin a
deep concern about prosecutorial
overreach led her to write a
best-selling book titled license to lie
exposing corruption in the Department of
Justice and along those lines she is
currently working as one of the lawyers
representing retired lieutenant General
Michael Flynn I think some of you in
this room may have heard of general
Flynn
she will be speaking today on how to fix
justice would you please welcome to the
podium Sidney Powell
thank you all so much
really I'm honored to be here and speak
to this auspicious group I've met a lot
of fascinating and caring people I want
to thank you first for the gift of your
time in being here today that's the most
valuable thing you can give anyone it's
the only one of our assets that cannot
be replaced in any way shape or form so
I'm especially grateful that you care
enough about all these issues in
Hillsdale College to be a part of this I
think it's extraordinary I didn't learn
about Hillsdale until a few years ago
actually I've never been political and
didn't think I was being political I
wrote license to lie but I found out it
was so here I am Politico did what they
tried to make a hit piece on me and I
think I haven't even read the whole
thing yet but my son read it for me and
he said really the worst thing they
could say about you where I'm you're a
mag a loving lawyer so I'll take that
[Music]
how many of you have read licensed to
lie exposing corruption in the
Department of Justice okay not all that
many well I learned from our excellent
prior speaker mr. Searcy that I did a
few things right
I wrote it too it reads like a John
Grisham novel so it's a relatively easy
fast read in that way people have called
it a page-turner
I literally prayed I would not have to
write license to lie and I prayed I
would not have to write it because for
me to have to sit down and write it
meant that the system of justice that I
believed in and had practiced in for I
guess about 25 years by that time was
broken and that was a very very sad
thing for me so it was extremely
emotional to write the book and I wrote
it because I in that way of telling a
story because I wanted people to feel to
feel the toll that a wrongful criminal
conviction takes on everyone in the
process it is outrageous it is
devastating and if you've not been in
the unfortunate position of having the
entire might and weight of the United
States Department of Justice focused
against you to literally crush you you
cannot begin to comprehend what it's
like for those who are and I would
venture to guess that approximately five
percent of our current prison population
state and federal is completely innocent
and another five percent at least is or
was the subject of a trial so unfair and
judges so prejudiced that you can't tell
if they were rightly convicted or not
that is a serious problem in this
country we should not have one innocent
person in prison
mr. Arne and I were talking earlier at
lunch about the whole separate topic of
prison reform which we need every bit as
much as we need reform in the Department
of Justice but I will start by saying
that I think the first way to fix
justice right now is to drop the charges
against lieutenant General Michael Flynn
and we are in the process of trying to
convince the Department of Justice to do
that right now
the especially good news is that
Attorney General Barr has assigned mr.
Jensen the United States Attorney in
Missouri to take a look at the case I'm
not sure exactly what his role is I
understand he will not be appearing on
the pleadings and I wouldn't expect him
to but hopefully he's going to take a
fresh and independent look at all the
motions that we have filed since I came
in the case because we have outlined an
atrocious series of in justices that
should offend everyone in the country
they literally made up the charges
against general Flynn and the case
against him exemplifies everything that
is wrong now with our criminal justice
system
we have prosecutors in the Department of
Justice and across the United States
Attorneys offices that have determined
they can weaponize our system of Justice
to prosecute people for political
reasons they are an expert at making up
crimes and they have become more expert
along with FBI agents with making up
facts to go with those crimes that's
exactly what we've seen in the case
against general Flynn there really is no
case he was honest with the agents we
learned with material the government did
give us that the agents said they
thought his demeanor was sure he was
being perfectly forthright with them
although he didn't remember some things
and they left that interview with him On
January 24th in the White House by which
they ambushed him by the way you know
mr. McCabe told him oh you don't need
you don't need counsel there's no reason
for that really and led him to believe
that it was an entirely different
scenario after I got in the case we
found out that they had even schemed and
planned to interview him in such a way
that he would not real
he was even being investigated because
he was national security adviser they
didn't want to ruffle any feathers and
leave with any sort of animosity coming
from him that he was being investigated
so they were they planned they had a
series of meetings at the highest levels
of the FBI and to decide how and when to
interview him in such a way that he
would not even realize he was the
subject of the interview much less being
advised of his rights which of course
they didn't do because they didn't want
to tip him off in the slightest way that
they were investigating him
and since he's worked with FBI agents
for any number of years in his career he
saw them as allies and they even
remarked about that after they left the
interview about how successful they were
in keeping him relaxed and unguarded and
thinking of them as friends for the
government to then bring a criminal
prosecution against someone for alleged
false statements in that kind of
scenario is simply beyond the pale I
don't know of any other false statements
prosecution in the history of our
country that rests on unwarned
uninformed about even being the subject
of an investigation statements made to
people you perceived as allies that is
the biggest set up of someone I have
ever seen and only in the last month a
little over a month now did we learn
that one of the two agents who
interviewed general Flynn had been
slipped surreptitiously into a sample
presidential briefing of candidate Trump
as the nominee on August 17 2016
precisely for the purpose of assessing
general Flynn's demeanor taking notes
reporting back anything he might have
said that would be relevant to the
crossfire hurricane investigation as
they called it of the purported Russia
collusion which we all know as a hoax
they sent him there to do that precise
thing and they hid that from general
Flynn and his defense team the entire
time even though Judge Emmett Sullivan
who has the case had given issued what's
called a Brady order ordering the
government to produce any evidence that
might be favorable or material to the
defense well the fact that that agent
had done that assessment of general
Flynn and been in on that interview not
only shows what we call egregious
government misconduct because it
violated completely the trust that is
supposed to exist between the nominee or
the president and the people who do a
presidential daily briefing like that
but it also showed that that agents
assessment of general Flynn then on the
24th when he came out of that meeting
with general Flynn the ambush interview
as I call it his assessment and the
validity of his belief that general
Flynn was being honest and truthful with
the agents just became exponentially
greater and more valid so there were two
serious issues that arise from our
notification that that agent was in
excuse me was in that meeting on August
17 another thing it tells us is and I
think you'll find this particularly
interesting this just a brief timeline
of what went on there it was August 15
2016 that we have the page struck text
messages the to illicit FBI lovers that
were having affairs even though one was
a counterintelligence agent and one was
special counsel to Deputy Director
McCabe you would think they would have
sense enough not to do something that
would subject them or risk them being
amenable to blackmail and
all kinds of problems but they did they
were both cheating on their spouses with
each other and somehow that they managed
to keep that a secret from the world's
best investigatory agency kind of calls
it all into question doesn't it how good
is the upper echelon of the FBI or any
of it for that matter if the two top
people on the Muellers squad and in the
FBI can carry on like that and nobody
notices not to mention over 50,000 text
messages between the two of them I mean
I'm still trying to figure out when they
had time to work and we've only seen a
few of the text messages between them
the government that's another thing
they're hiding they have not produced
all the strong page text messages even
all the ones that relate to general
Flynn but they were doing this and on
August 15 is when they text each other
about the infamous insurance policy we
just discussed this in in McCabe's
office it's like an insurance policy in
the event that Trump is elected August
16 is when they open the investigation
against general Flynn in August 17 the
very next day is when this agent whose
name I can't reveal although the entire
public I think knows who he is but I'm
under I've seen it under a protective
order so I can't tell you his name but
he goes into that presidential daily
briefing to assess general Flynn
specifically in the event they need to
interview him later as a subject so it's
just one act of extraordinary government
misconduct the other the FBI actually
cleared him completely of any offense
and there's a memo to that effect held
within the Department of Justice dated
January 30 2017 that's while he was
still in the White House it exonerates
him of being an agent of Russia the
agents reported back immediately on Jan
twenty-fourth doing three separate
briefings of an hour each to all the
upper echelon of DOJ and the FBI that
they thought he was being honest he
showed no signs of lying they believed
him and so they write that memo and it's
in the DOJ file I still haven't been
able to get judged Emmitt Sullivan to
produce that to the defense the
government refuses to give it to us they
say oh it really doesn't matter because
I doesn't have anything to do with the
false statements he made On January 24th
six days earlier well it has everything
to do with it
and and most people can see that but
Judge Sullivan despite the fact he's
actually the judicial hero of my book
license to lie because he presided over
the prosecution of former Alaska senator
Ted Stevens the longest serving
Republican in the United States Senate
and if you remember the prosecution of
Senator Stevens had to be thrown out
because the government had hidden
evidence that showed senator Stevens was
innocent and they had hidden evidence
that showed that undermine the testimony
of the government's few witnesses
against him and completely contradicted
the government's case it's happening all
over again now when I wrote licensed
Ally I did it to try to scream and and
wake up the general public to see how
weaponized and politicized the
Department of Justice had become and it
didn't just begin with Obama it's been
going on for at least twenty years as
best I can tell it's it starts in the
book with the Enron task force which was
created by President Bush and untethered
from the Department of Justice a group
of hand-picked prosecutors by Michael
Chertoff and Larry Thompson and Bob
Muller
sadly they picked them because they were
terrorists of prosecutors that's not
what a federal prosecutor is supposed to
be there is a Supreme Court decision
called Berger versus United States it
describes the role of an Asst US
attorney or Assistant US Attorney as
being a representative of the sovereign
whose job is to seek justice not
convictions and when I was an assistant
US attorney in three different districts
under nine different US attorneys from
both political parties across the
country Texas and Virginia any US
attorney I worked with or for said your
job is to do the right thing you know
make sure before you indict somebody
that they're actually guilty that it's a
real crime we don't need to stretch the
law we just need to enforce it and
that's what we did
nobody ever chastise me for losing a
jury trial and I lost several no one
ever chastise me for what's called
confessing error which means sometimes
is the appellate lawyer for the
appellate section in San Antonio or
Northern District Texas I had to go in
and admit to the Fifth Circuit that the
agents or the trial attorneys had done
something wrong that they had had blown
the case in some way and the conviction
had to be reversed the government
doesn't do that now they don't seem to
have done that much if any in the last
20 years and I don't know why that is
there is an extraordinary change in the
culture of the FBI and the Department of
Justice that must be reversed and the
time to reverse that is right now this
cannot go on any longer I really like
Attorney General Bill Barr he
understands the importance of the rule
of law
if we don't reinstate the rule of law
right now our republic is going to be
gone I mean that's how serious it is at
least a hundred million people in the
country see the two-tiered system we
have if you're a Republican you're going
to prison for
years if you're a Democrat you get a
pass you don't have to look any farther
than the special counsels indictment of
Paul Manafort which whatever man affords
real crimes were and apparently there
were some real tax crimes charged
against him the indictment also includes
person a or b I think who was Tony
Podesta who committed some of the exact
same offenses Mr Man afford did if not
more but was Tony Podesta indicted know
Tony Podesta just closed down one
company and went to start another or
door do something else
but he wasn't prosecuted at all he was
given a pass and everyone can see the
extraordinary crimes committed by
Hillary Clinton that were actual
offenses like destroying the
blackberries and destroying hundreds of
thousands of emails and absolutely
nothing was done immunity was handed out
to her colleagues as if it was Halloween
candy and at the same time two years
later everyone related to President
Trump is indicted have to sell their
houses to pay legal fees take out third
mortgages to pay legal fees and go to
prison we cannot survive as a republic
with dual standards like that and it's
absolute death for the rule of law I do
believe bill Barr understands that
someone asked me earlier if this was a
real tiff between bill Barr and
president Trump about the tweets
probably yes and and no there's no
danger of Bill Barr leaving and the
president thinks the world of him as I
say it the president's tweets often give
voice to what the people are thinking
and Bill Barr is solid enough and
self-assured enough and knows what he's
doing too simply absolutely ignore the
president's tweets and if the president
wants to take up a real issue with him
he can pick up the phone and calling
because
bar does serve at the pleasure of the
President of the United States that's
the way it ought to be
that's how voters are allowed to effect
change who was it Obama who said
elections have consequences well
hopefully the election of President
Trump and the mandatory re-election of
President Trump if we're going to save
the Republic will result in even more
favorable changes whether anyone else
likes it or not because the time is now
we simply cannot wait any longer I
applaud the president's Pardons and
commutations there are even more that
need to be made Bernie Kerik was
targeted after he was nominated as
President Bush's homeland security
person there no telling how many people
he insulted and offended when he was
police commissioner in New York but I
firmly believe that he was absolutely
targeted and I'm delighted the president
gave him a pardon I would encourage the
President to put Bernie Kerik in charge
of the Bureau of Prisons as high up as
he could put him because Carrick was
also head of the New York prison system
and cleaned up Rikers Island he cut down
inmate on inmate violence he streamlined
the budget everything worked better
he made dramatic improvements in Rikers
we need those same improvements made in
our prison system because it is just a
cesspool of corruption there's hardly
much difference between the criminals
behind the bars in some instances and
the ones outside the bars who are
smuggling in drugs and all kinds of
contraband and profiting from it and
stealing blindly from the prison system
itself so that's you know that's how to
fix the prison system how to fix justice
is to start changing the culture in the
FBI where they are trained at Quantico
and in the Department of Justice itself
there are a whole lot of people that
need to be fired and I really think it's
time we start some kind of personality
tests for narcissism and that narcissist
should not apply
[Music]
[Applause]
no matter how bad a criminal descendant
is and how much they need to go to
prison and there are plenty that fall in
that category standing there as a
prosecutor at a sentencing still always
gave me a knot in the pit of my stomach
because I hate to think about somebody
having to having to go to prison no
matter who they are and obviously we
have to have them people who are
dangerous and I prosecuted many of those
people who had killed people massive
drug rings in western Texas we had we
had everything we had a federal judge
assassinated shortly after I got there
and the Bandidos motorcycle gang then
tried to kill the prosecutor two doors
down from me it was literally the the
Wild West for a little while
fortunately I was so young I thought I
was bulletproof and there wasn't the
Internet for my parents to worry about
me and they didn't know how kind of
rough it was those first few years in
Western District of Texas but yes you
know obviously we prisons are for people
who are dangerous as Pat Nolan with the
ACU says they should not just be for
people we are mad at we need to come up
with much more creative ways of helping
people reform and either kick their drug
habits or or educate them to the point
where they can do something positive for
the country instead of spending an
average of forty thousand dollars per
prisoner and tax dollars each year to
have them rot away I would encourage
that you not only read license to lie
but also Carrick's book called from
jailor to jailed because between those
two you will get an overview of pretty
much everything that's wrong in our
criminal justice system
Harvey silverglade is a former Harvard
lawyer who wrote a book called three
felonies a day and the premise of that
is that there are so many criminal laws
now that any normal person going about
their daily business commits three
felonies every day
without even knowing it that is the
problem of over criminalization Congress
and everybody says oh there ought to be
a law against that so Congress passes
the law against that and the next thing
you know there's a twitter feed called a
crime a day and that's that's what we've
got I mean they've made federal
regulations that ought to be purely
civil into criminal offenses and people
don't even know the regulations exist in
lots of cases we've got to have a
Walmart size rollback on things that
have been over criminalized on top of
that we have overzealous and creative
prosecutors who literally make up crimes
one of the things I talk about in
license to lie is the destruction of
Arthur Andersen the venerable accounting
firm and 85,000 jobs across the United
States and other countries
it was the notorious Enron task force
prosecutors that indicted Andersen they
did it by piecing together parts of two
different statutes to make a crime out
of something that was not a crime in
fact Congress later passed
sarbanes-oxley to fill what they
perceived as the gap in the law that
allowed Andersen to be reversed and sure
enough the Supreme Court reversed Arthur
Andersen in a unanimous decision that
included Justice Ginsburg and others
that we often rail about but the
Andersen conviction was so egregious the
decision was unanimous the prosecutors
had both made up a crime and they had
succeeded in persuading a Republican
judge in Houston to take all indication
of criminal intent out of the jury
instructions well its criminal intent
that separates a crime from a civil
wrong so if you don't have criminal
intent you should not be convicted of a
crime however no problem for the Enron
task force prosecutors just
suade the district judge to take
criminal intent out of the jury
instructions they could have convicted
the Pope those prosecutors after
destroying Arthur Andersen turned their
sights on Merrill Lynch I'm convinced
that the reason they destroyed Anderson
and they knew that's exactly what they
were going to do because Anderson
represented 25 hundred publicly traded
companies they seal the indictment for a
week while they worked behind the scenes
to avoid upheavals in the markets before
they unseal the anderson indictment and
of course as soon as they unsealed it
the company had to fold I think over a
hundred and sixty civil plaintiffs piled
on on top of the criminal charges and
all their clients had already had to
leave so Anderson was history
immediately upon being indicted you
don't have to worry about a conviction
all you have to do is indict so that's
what they did and I think they did it so
that they could say then to any other
target particularly a company like
Merrill Lynch you saw what we just did
to Anderson you either agree to
everything we want or we will give you
the death penalty so sure enough when
they go to Merrill Lynch next Merrill
sons the most onerous non-prosecution
agreement I have ever seen they give up
all kinds of rights including of the
Merrill defendants that they offered up
essentially as sacrificial lambs for
Merrill executives the nicest people
you'd ever want to know were then
indicted by the Enron task force on the
offense of conspiring to help Enron or
deprive Enron of the honest services of
Andrew Fastow
now if Andrew Fastow ever gave anybody a
day of honest services that would be a
newsflash
but how anybody at Merrill Lynch could
have conspired to deprive Enron of of
Andrew fastest honest services is beyond
comprehension
there were no bribes there were no
kickbacks judge Ewing were line did the
trial it was it was a railroad operation
the defense were like deer in headlights
at every turn the Enron task force
prosecutors had named over a hundred
people in Houston as unindicted
co-conspirators which meant they all
lawyered up
the mural defendants could not even
speak with their own Merrill Lynch
inside House Counsel about the facts of
the case even though she had actually
handled the transaction from beginning
to end and knew things that they didn't
know the for Merrill Lynch executives
that were sacrificed on this case didn't
even have authority to approve the
transaction it had to be approved above
their heads and as judge Rowland said
the day he sentenced them all to prison
for up to four years I realize you were
just doing your jobs that day the
government decided that they were
responsible for the entire downfall of
Enron it didn't matter that the
transaction that they had done with
Merrill produced I think it was a thirty
million dollar profit for Enron or that
Merrill Lynch only made seven hundred
and seventy five thousand dollars or
that there were no bribes by these
defendants no kickbacks in fact my
client Jim Brown didn't even want to do
the deal he didn't trust Andrew Fastow
and he made that clear to everybody in
mural but like I said it was approved
above their heads they were convicted of
course by Houston jury the entirety of
Houston was just inflamed and sensed
essentially decimated by the destruction
of Enron the fall of Enron the big Enron
building became a shell there was one
under construction that didn't get
finished being built anywhere near that
time
little businesses all around had to
shudder people lost their retirement
savings across the country but without
going into you know what exactly caused
the downfall of Enron and it was far
more complicated than what the
prosecutors wanted to say it wasn't
because people were stealing money from
Enron and I'm not sure it was actually
criminal conduct with the exception of
the people that the government gave
really sweetheart deals to Andy Fastow
and his protege Michael Kapur with you
only two that actually stole any money
from Enron nobody they prosecuted stolen
he not even Ken layer or Jeff Skilling
and skilling got a 24 year prison
sentence more than most murderers get I
think he wound up serving 14 years and
the only way he got his sentence reduced
from 24 years to 14 years was by
dropping his motion for new trial which
included government misconduct claims
against then White House Counsel
Katherine Rummler who started her big
trail to success by being an inter on
task force prosecutor well the for
Merrill Lynch executives having been
convicted we can't even get the bail
pending appeal one of the other things
that needs to be fixed is that in
nonviolent cases we need a possibility
of having bail and allowing people to
stay out particularly in these complex
business prosecutions until their case
has been affirmed on appeal at the very
least our clients had to go to prison
before we could even file the appeal the
youngest Merrill Lynch executive that
was sent to prison was sent to a maximum
transfer a maximum security federal
transfer facility hundreds of miles from
his young children and family when we
finally got the Fifth Circuit to hear
the case on appeal he was represented by
Seth Waxman who wrote one of the best
insufficiency of the evidence briefs I
have ever read
I would commend it to the reading of any
lawyer it was just a anybody else
frankly it was a beautiful piece of work
and told the story of how this defendant
was had really no role in the
transaction at all but he spent eight
months in a maximum-security federal
transfer facility with the worst of the
worst because the Enron task force
prosecutors screwed these guys over
every way they could possibly find to do
it they were all sent different places
they were not put in prison camps or
Club fed as some people like to call it
none of their conditions were like that
this young man was completely acquitted
as soon as the Fifth Circuit got around
to hearing the appeal but that was eight
months after he spent in prison Jim
Brown my client served the longest time
he served a year because he'd also been
convicted of perjury and obstruction of
justice listen carefully to this perjury
and obstruction of justice two separate
counts for expressing his personal
understanding of a telephone call he did
not even participate in after Andrew
Weissman the prosecutor who was leading
the inrun task force told him to share
that understanding whether it was
accurate or not well folks if it's not
accurate I don't know how in the world
it can be perjury but I could not get
the Fifth Circuit Court of Appeals that
I have loved for decades to reverse that
conviction even worse six years into my
participation in the case I discover a
disc that the prosecutors had given
evidence before the trial had seen
evidence and reviewed it they had yellow
highlighted the evidence they knew was
completely exculpatory of these mural
defendants but they had hidden it for
six years the indictment itself made up
yet another crime which I knew is just
like when I read the Anderson
I saw that they'd made up a crime when I
read the Merrill Lynch indictment I saw
they'd made up a crime never in the
history of our country had there been a
prosecution of somebody for depriving
anyone of honest services without bribes
or kickbacks or some form of self
dealing but that's exactly what they've
done here we pointed that out to the
Fifth Circuit to try to get bail pending
appeal still couldn't get it so all for
Merrill defendants served between eight
months and a year in prison on an
indictment that did not even state a
federal offense while the prosecutors
were hiding the evidence that showed
they were innocent
I've been watched as those prosecutors
became Obama's longest-serving White
House Counsel the assistant attorney
general for the criminal division of the
Department of Justice who then
micromanage the prosecution of Senator
Ted Stevens that had to be thrown out
for hiding evidence that showed he was
innocent that was Matthew Friedrich
Katherine Rummler became Obama's
longest-serving White House Counsel
Leslie Caldwell was then brought back
into department of justice by Loretta
Lynch to head the criminal division she
had been the original head of the Enron
task force and then Andrew Weissman none
other than Andrew Weissman whose name
I'm sure you've heard he's now on MSNBC
was I called him the lead villain of
license to lie because he was the ramrod
of all of this he was one of the most
terroristic of the terrors of
prosecutors he became Muller's deputy
director and general counsel of the FBI
and then after a stint in private
practice where he made a lot of money
Leslie Caldwell brought him back in to
the Department of Justice as what I call
the deep state transition team to help
with the Russia hoax and he then became
the head person on Muller Special
Counsel operation if you want a little
entertainment go to our website I did I
have a weird sense of humor I call it
creeps on a mission dot-com
and there's a t-shirt to go with it
it's it's Robert Muller and Andrew
Weissman Peter Strock and Lisa Paige
Bruce or at Department of Justice and
Andy McCabe and James Comey behind a
battered seal of the Department of just
- us and the eagle on the seal of the
Department of Justice has his wing
across as as hanging his head and shame
you can blow up the art on your computer
screen and there's a lot of fun detail
in there that you have to expand it to
see but one of the things this homie
become he's holding up Hillary Clinton's
computer about to hit delete on 33,000
emails and Andrew Weissman's stuffing
yellow highlighted FBI interview reports
called 302s back into his briefcase and
there's some interesting names on the
302s but I didn't realize well I mean I
saw the train coming I didn't realize it
would be coming at President Trump when
I wrote licensed to lie but I was really
glad that I published it in 2014 so that
there was a warning ahead of time about
what was going on and then I knew as
soon as I heard the Russia hoax and and
all that and Muller picked Weissman for
his task force exactly what was going to
happen
in fact manna forts defense team said
licensed ally they read it because they
knew it was Muller's handbook his
playbook what times we live in
Harvey silverglade and I published
together just in the last few weeks I
think it came out a book called
conviction machine standing up to
federal prosecutorial abuse and in that
book we do propose solutions for
criminal justice reform and how to fix
justice in general we've only got it we
only featured about ten different things
there obviously it's a much more
complicated problem but one very
one is to insist that FBI agents when
they interview people record the
conversation either by audio or video
right now they don't Muller testified in
Congress against it come me probably
testified in Congress against it but
what that means is then the FBI agents
take whatever notes they want and they
write their 302 report and as in general
Flynn's case it's being used to
prosecute him supposedly it reflects his
false statements when it doesn't reflect
those at all in fact we think we can't
haven't even been able to get the
original 302 which somehow is missing
despite the fact it goes into the FBI's
Sentinel system and cannot be missing I
hope the first thing mr. Jensen does is
insist that Brandon Mann grek the
prosecutor in our case produces to him
the original 302 and the audit trail
that is always in the FBI's Sentinel
system because I think if he does that
and it would only take about 48 hours he
will see for one reason or another this
case has to be dismissed we've already
shown evidence that they literally made
major modifications to the 302 between
the nights of February 10th and 11th
which happens to be the same time they
showed the transcripts of the Flynn kis
Liat call to vice president pence and
Lisa Paige instructed instructed Peter
Strock to make the changes she had left
on somebody's chair and they added
sentences into the 302 that weren't even
reflected or referred to in their notes
at all their notes had material
misstatement in it or the 302 did there
was one issue where they literally one
had the word not and one didn't have the
word not so I'd kind of call that a
direct contradiction
that didn't mean that Judge Sullivan
though would order their production of
that despite the fact he's the judicial
hero of licensed Elihu throughout the
Ted Stevens conviction he denied my
request for Brady evidence in a 92 page
decision that completely slammed us
denied absolutely everything even though
there is a I couldn't even get the
January 30 memo from DOJ that exonerates
Flynn of everything they went to talk to
him about we've got a problem with our
federal judges - it crosses both
political boundaries licensed a lot
crosses Republican and Democratic
administrations it's only gotten worse
sokeep attorney general bar in your
prayers I know you keep general Flynn in
your prayers and I know a lot of you
have told you told me that you're
praying for me - I want everybody to
know that he and I both feel it I know
that we will get this straightened out I
will not quit until general Flynn is
acquitted or exonerated or all charges
are dismissed
thank you very much we are operating
from a Defense Fund
it's the Mike Flynn Defense Fund org and
the generosity of the American people
has been very impressive I have no idea
where the fund stands right now I try
not to ask I can tell you that all the
lawyers have cut their fees I'm billing
at the rate of about what Covington and
Burling charged for their librarian yep
the Covington bills were pretty
impressive I think he paid them over 3.5
million dollars to walk him into a
proffer that he never should have gone
to and enter a plea of guilty to crimes
a crime he did not commit so we're in
the process of straightening all that
out but I fully intend to do it and we
appreciate everyone's prayers cards
notes emails of support it's been a very
fulfilling experience to feel the
outpouring of support from across the
country so thank you all for that and we
can fix the Department of Justice and we
can fix the FBI it does have to start
with a change in culture a lot more
people need to be fired and a lot more
power needs to be given to the inspector
generals for each of the agencies that I
think the Department of Justice is the
only one where nobody actually
investigates the lawyers for their
egregious misconduct and even President
Bush stopped the practice of publishing
the names of lawyers who had been found
to have committed ethical violations or
been sanctioned in any way I think that
public exposure needs to come back for
acts of misconduct and I would also
encourage
I would also encourage the Attorney
General to make it very clear to every
FBI agent and every prosecutor that any
intentional and deliberate failure to
provide evidence to the defense that is
exculpatory and favorable to the defense
will be met with a serious suspension
the first time and if it happens to no I
take that back if they do it
deliberately and intentionally they
should be fired
accidental will take a short suspension
without pay but intentional they must be
fired because it amounts to obstruction
of justice were it done by anybody else
putting together the false charges that
they put together against general Flynn
isn't itself obstruction of justice
creating the falsifying the Carter page
email that they use to get the warrant
is obstruction of justice the Department
of Justice is going to have to start
prosecuting some of its own by the same
standards it seeks to hold the rest of
us
and I'm hopeful that that's we're gonna
see developments along those lines very
shortly it just can't take much longer
because the public we can't take much
longer everybody is ready to see things
happen right now and with that I would
like to I'll open it to questions
[Applause]
sorry to bug up your onion thank you
very much I forgot to mention when I
introduced Sidney Powell that our talk
today is sponsored by the Stone --is--
foundation so Sidney Paul's talk today
is sponsored by the Stone Age foundation
and with that thank you and with that we
have time for some questions we have
students with microphones please wait
for the microphone to be brought to you
and we'll have some Q&A thank you thank
you for your presentation
I'm remembering during the Justice
Cavanaugh's hearings senator Blumenthal
from Connecticut introduced the Latin
phrase that refers to a witness who is
untruthful on one matter may be taken
taking is untruth on other matters is
there a similar phrase for prosecutors
who exhibit misconduct in one matter and
what we should expect in other matters I
just call them liars and snakes okay
thank you for your remarks and god bless
you and I hope you succeed thank you we
will I have a question regarding
attorney general sessions where was he
almost all those years that he was in
office it seems to me a lot of
corruption was going on too going on
right under his nose why didn't he speak
up well I think attorney general
sessions is a good person but he was not
equipped to do that job he allowed the
career prosecutors some of whom have
recently left the department to persuade
him that it would be an ethical
violation for him to continue just
because he'd shaken hands with
Ambassador kis lyac and in a pass
through social situation I think it was
that was ridiculous he should not have
recused if he was going to recuse I
think he get the very least he should
have told the president he felt that way
before he took the job because it's
essentially
left us in the quagmire we've been in
with the Muller investigation of course
also blame Deputy Attorney General
Rosenstein who apparently just
completely fell apart at the thought of
it all and that's why he punted to
Special Counsel either that or he was
completely in on it but none of it was
right there should never have been a
special counsel appointed there was no
investigating investigatory validity to
hand off to a special counsel they knew
that and the reason we have the
prosecution of general Flynn I'm
convinced is to maintain the obstruction
hoax to allow it to go forward for two
years because Muller knew within a day
or two
there was no Ruscha collusion the FBI
had already been investigating it and
trying to create it for six months and
hadn't even been able to do that but
when Comey went to the White House on
February 14th which was the day after
general Flynn left he had that
conversation with the president in which
the president said wha hope you can see
to let this thing go Flynn's a really
good guy and then Comey runs out and
creates one of his famous dear diary
memos and says that's obstruction of
justice and he starts you know breeding
the whole obstruction of justice theory
when what he should have told the
president before February 14th even was
that they had investigated Flynn and
cleared him of everything the agents
believed he was telling the truth there
were no lies in the January 24th meeting
and they had written a memo to DOJ on
the 30th of January that he was not an
agent of Russia which was a ridiculous
assertion in the first place what
they've also failed to mention and will
not give me are his briefings and
debriefings with the Defense
Intelligence Agency for whom he
continued to work as a citizen after he
left the agency he briefed and debriefed
and collected information for our
government when he went to Russia and
gave it to them they knew about every
foreign contact he had because he was
keeping them informed
he kept his security clearance it's just
mind-boggling that they've gotten by
with this this long absolutely
mind-boggling and terrifying because
there but for the grace of God goes any
one of us attorney general in charge to
not prosecute Andrew McCabe yes the
McCabe issue read the declination on
McCabe it's it's a very narrow issue
they've only declined to prosecute him
on the statements about his leaks to the
Wall Street Journal I am okay with that
because I think they are looking at
McCabe with much bigger fish to fry and
I have heard that there are two sealed
indictments waiting in the wings I'm not
sure what they're waiting for
at first I would have assumed that they
were definitely waiting for the
impeachment the ridiculous impeachment
issue to be over but I'm not sure now
what the answer to that might be other
than maybe some people are trying to
make a deal but I think we will see some
indictments within the next few months
of the people who really need to be
indicted
[Applause]
we have a question on the speakers right
I have a two-part questions Cindy
the first one is where's John Durham's
report number one and number two is is
there such a thing in the law as race if
so facto and the reason I mentioned that
when Hillary particular server to our
private residence
that's race if so facto if I remember
the old expression is there such a thing
anymore yes it's actually raised up so
loquitur the thing speaks for itself
what happened was the double standard is
what happened I wrote an article for the
New York Observer ages ago called the
countless crimes of Hillary Clinton that
went viral I think rush might have even
read it online on there they're probably
things she could still be indicted for
and frankly I think should because the
Espionage Act
[Applause]
very clear violations of the Espionage
Act and really no issue about intent
despite President Obama proclaiming
otherwise and of course you realize the
reason that Hillary had to be protected
was because he was writing her on that
secret server using an alias which shows
that he damn well knew and had approved
in advance her use of the secret
unsecured server on top of that there's
the Anthony Weiner laptop which I don't
know if you heard this I wrote an
article about that to 675,000 Clinton
emails when they got Anthony Weiner's
laptop in a search warrant because of
all his sex perversion issues it was all
the Clinton emails the Clinton
Foundation her Secretary of State emails
Huma Abha Dean's
emails lots of people emailed Huma as a
proxy for Hillary and it included what
Comey called the gulp sorry let's wave
my hands more than most people they the
golden emails because they were the
BlackBerry backup emails that they were
supposedly just looking for everywhere
very diligently well guess what they did
when they found him on the Weiner laptop
they got a search warrant for things
that didn't include the BlackBerry
backup emails so when they told us when
he stood there and said that day oh you
know we've we've reviewed all the emails
now there's nothing there that was a
bald-faced lie they specifically did not
look at the BlackBerry backups and they
didn't look at a fraction of the emails
on Anthony Weiner's laptop so one of the
things if I were the president I'd do is
demand the Anthony Weiner laptop and get
it to the most trusted person in the
military to take apart everything on it
and then start using it there's a lot
that can be prosecuted I have no doubt
on that laptop and first in fact I heard
that the New York police officers who
saw some of it even though they're
hardened investigators literally had to
go throw up it's bad
question to the speakers left Sydney I
think I speak for everybody in this room
and saying thank you for your courage
thank you for being a great great great
American and your perseverance and doing
what you do and being who you are with
with that being said from the previous
speaker I think we need to get Nick back
in here because there's plenty of moving
material right here we could we can make
movies for a long time about this I also
want to thank you for a conversation I
had with mat Whitaker about five months
ago and the deep state word came up or
the hyphenated word and he said you know
I just can't tell you a lot of things
but I can tell you one thing every day
you should thank God that Donald J Trump
is your president and and I want to say
this to everybody in this room go out of
here and convince somebody who wasn't
gonna vote for him to vote for him this
our country's at stake this is not a
game and last but not least my question
for you is can you help us understand
how this happens that these people are
so obviously obviously criminal and it
just gets blown over it just gets passed
over they never get prosecuted in a
heart do they think we're that stupid
out here thank thank you again they've
had so much power and gotten by with it
for so long and they're so narcissistic
their hubris is just beyond bounds they
can't even fathom
I mean Comey I don't think I don't know
what to say about kind of me I mean
really I mean the man is so full of
himself and and unfounded
self-righteousness and hubris
he thinks he's untouchable and has done
nothing wrong when he almost destroyed
the
our FBI single-handedly it's a
reputation it will take years to recover
it's got to be rebuilt from the ground
up because it's really 20 years at least
of that attitude Muller had it and Kumi
had it and that covers 16 years or more
so it's got to be rebuilt from the
ground up and people trained to restore
fidelity bravery and integrity the key
word there being integrity because if
our law enforcement agents and agencies
are not completely honest we are lost
I'm a ditto head so I'm gonna ditto what
the fellow over here said thank you but
I'm also a grandma great grandma from
Ohio I've listened to rush since he came
on the air and I learned a lot well one
of the things is it's common sense has
died in this country everything you said
is just common sense it makes me sick to
listen to the news anymore and listening
to you really makes me want to throw up
yeah I think that's why they save me for
the last they didn't want you know I did
not recognize your name but that's a
minute you opened your mouth I
recognized your voice because I've heard
you many times on the radio and every
somebody says I have an accent
whatever it is every time I hear your
voice I think oh this is gonna be good I
think you have such good comments on the
radio and your speech today was one of
the most powerful I've ever heard so I
have no question accept advice take care
of yourself to your girl
thank you we need people like you thank
you thank you very much
[Applause]
would you comment on Roger stones Fiasco
I have not read the transcript in the
Roger stone case so I really can't
comment on the validity of the case I
can tell you that they rushed to indict
him I can certainly tell you that the
way they arrested him is an egregious
abuse of power maeap alling the same
thing they did to Paul Manafort they
literally you know went into his house
in the dark of night with his family and
wife sleeping in the bed they searched
his wife at gunpoint in their bed in her
nightgown I mean can you men even
imagine that happening in your homes and
having to lay there powerless and watch
as FBI agents searched your wife in her
nightgown in the bed
it was egregious and they should be
punished just for that I mean the the
director of the FBI can certainly set a
policy and he is responsible for that
because those FBI agents were still
under his authority he's on TV
complaining about how they don't have
money because if you'll recall it
happened during the government shutdown
but that didn't stop them from sending
16 vehicles a boat frog men and a
helicopter to go get Roger stone who
would have walked in the next morning
with his sunglasses and hat on and
surrendered the four prosecutors that
resigned haven't resigned far enough
only one of them is leaving the
department the others are still part of
the department or a US Attorney's Office
there are still any number of Muller
people in the department and in the FBI
probably every FBI agent that was
involved in that needs to be scrutinized
carefully and assigned to help improve
things in Alaska or an Indian
Reservation or
something like that they they all well
Christopher Rey admitted the other day
in his testimony that every agent who's
mentioned in the Inspector General's 475
page report on the FISA abuses is under
investigation we have time for one more
question
will those chuckleheads see jail time
and how much yeah I think some will see
jail time I think the ones at the top
will see jail time I'm not a big
proponent of lengthy jail sentences for
white-collar crime but I think there is
a certain benefit to having that
experience for at least long enough to
make you realize it's real and then for
example I was talking to mr. Arne about
Madoff I would have sent Madoff to
prison for maybe a year and then I would
have put him on an ankle bracelet and
made him live in Section eight housing
and work 12 hours a day in a soup
kitchen you know he's not dangerous to
society as long as you don't let him
near a computer or give him any money
but he instead of us paying $40,000 a
year in tax dollars to keep him in
federal prison he could be out doing
something to serve somebody else and I
would think you know the same thing
would be true for Hillary Clinton and
and other people that maybe in the scope
[Applause]
thank you all so much for for everything
the hospitality has been wonderful it's
been my honor to be here and thank you
for your prayers
you